hello everyone
uh and welcome to today's webinar the
power of autofluorescence extraction
using full spectrum profiling i am
laurent genestetoraki
product manager here at scitec
biosciences and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we have about 10 minutes to answer
questions at the end of the presentation
live and more information can also be
found at www.scitecbio.com
thank you to libraries for hosting this
webinar it is an educational webinar and
thus free
and best offers free continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education window at the
bottom of your screen to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
diana benia escobar
our u.s technical lead for application
support here at scitec
fiona you may now begin your
presentation
morning everyone thank you for joining
us today my goal is to
show you the power of using full
spectrum profiling when you are
understanding the autofluorescence in
cells in suspension
by using flow cytometry this is the
first part of a three lecture series
focus on this topic of autofluorescence
which is that natural emission of light
that we observe
in south and what we will discuss today
is
three main topics uh first
autofluorescence what is it where does
it come from how it changes
and then that particular technology that
we use full spectrum profiling
what it is about how it works and
finally how we can use that technology
in order to understand autofluorescence
the main player for the talk
characterizing that autofluorescence and
finally
being able to extract it if needed in
order to get better resolution for your
flow cytometry data
if we start with autofluorescence in in
microscopy or in flow cytometry we know
there's a
background noise baseline signal that is
just coming from
unstained cells all that natural
emission of fluorescent light
that's coming from biological structure
within the cells in your sample
and the ability to capture
autofluorescence has been used in
multiple
fields including clinical applications
because
changes in autofluorescence can also
serve as diagnostic
indicators for example this is an image
of our right
eye that shows hyper autofluorescence in
a patient with
a vision loss cause by toxicity and the
point is this outer fluorescence a hyper
outer fluorescence in the perimoucular
area was critical
as an indicator for diagnosis
if we focus then on cells in suspension
and flow cytometry
and or even microscopy as the images i'm
going to show
autofluorescence it's all the light
coming from cells
that is detected in the absence of any
exogenous stain or reported agent
what i'm showing you here it's cells
leukocytes different types
after they are excited with a uv laser
what we are seeing is natural emission
of light
in different patterns different
intensities
and those differences are going to be
based on how big the cells are how
granular they are
also their metabolic state for example
if we compare leukemic cells with
normal cells in the leukemics we see
that our fluorescence in a more
uniform distribution we barely see any
of the cellular structures that you
could see in a normal cell
and it's not only changes in how the
light is looking the distribution the
amount of light and the pattern
it's also the wavelength at which that
light that's being
emitted if we compare for example
different wavelengths from 400 to 800
what we are seeing is untreated cells
they have more of a blue emission
profile versus cells treated with a
cytotoxic agent
it's more of a red emission what we
could be capturing
so multiple differences in that
autofluorescence in the different
parameters for that
autofluorescence characterization and
how that changes
based on cell size granularity the
metabolic state
and different experimental conditions as
we are seeing here
so autofluorescence comes from
endogenous molecules
that become fluorescent when they are
excited by the lasers in your cytometers
that includes components involving
structural or metabolic functions in the
cells
structural proteins like the ones in the
extracellular metrics like collagen
elastin
for the organelles all the
dynamics in fusion and clustering of
these organelles in response to
metabolic stress
it's going to be influencing
autofluorescence
and in terms of metabolites we have
metabolic cofactors
amino acids lipopigments that also emit
autofluorescence if we characterize that
emission in terms of the wavelength
of emission we see that usually most of
them
they absorb in the uv to blue range and
ended up emitting that light
uh from the blue to the red uh
range as well the difference proteins
have
characteristic excitation emission
profiles
and the different components also are
related to specific
set types if we want to understand
autofluorescence is a very dynamic
process it can increase or decrease
based on multiple factors
one of them is physiological processes
when cells are growing when they are
proliferating when they are producing
energy there is higher out of
fluorescence also pathological
conditions we know
stress response oxidative damage disease
things like hypoxia inflammation cancer
can change the autofluorescence pattern
and in experimental conditions during
the staining protocol for example we
know that
all aldehyde fixation transfection
reagents
hybridization buffers increase the
amount of autofluorescence
in the cells in general what we know is
that we will have
higher autofluorescence levels in cells
that are larger
there are more granular cells that are
stress or dines
they are producing more energy and more
proteins
and also cells with more content and
more activity in lysosomes and
mitochondria are going to be
having more autofluorescence
we know then that out of fluorescence
for microscopy and for flow cytometry it
can be problematic
because it can interfere that baseline
can interfere with their detection of
your real fluorescent light
masking log expressors or even
interfering with
dim fluorochromes or low express markers
what you can do with autofluorescence
the traditional approach is just work
around it
reduce that unwanted autofluorescence by
using quenchers this is an example
these are red blood cells this is the
real fluorescence and what we are seeing
is that if you quench
the red blood cells you ended up seeing
the specific fluorescence you are
interested in
another tool could be optimizing your
staining protocol
reducing the concentration of your
fixative reducing the amount of serum
that is present in the staining buffer
removing the cells removing
extracellular matrix
lies in your red blood cells could help
as well
and finally a way to work around
autofluorescence is
use red fluoresce fluores are not going
to be impacted by that light that
autofluorescence it's adding
into your samples things like apc alexa
fluoro 647
alexa plural 700 are not impacted as we
will be seeing
in the plots by autofluorescence so a
good option to characterize markers in
that area
another option once you have
characterized or captured the light from
autofluorescence
and the light from your real fluorescent
signal in this case gfp
what you can do is computational removal
of that
background in order to get better
resolution better
signal to noise ratio that's what we
call
extraction of autofluorescence and
finally what you could do is take
advantage of the signal you are
capturing in autofluorescence or in
unstained cells
this is an example there's a transverse
section of a pine needle
we are seeing here is after exciting the
cells
with a laser without any exogenous
dye or staining what we're seeing is
that the natural emission
chlorophyll this red emission and also
flavonoids on the cell walls
plants have pigments that are going to
be fluorescent after excitation by
multiple lasers
and that's what you could capture so
that's critical not only to take pretty
pictures
but also to understand changes in that
emission profile when you have
photosynthesis
co2 assimilation changes in ph
and also treatment with different
chemicals and
measure those differences without using
any label
or staining so full spectrum profiling
going back to the other player in the
talk full spectrum profiling
is a technology that enables you to do
either extraction
correct characterize this
autofluorescence and remove it
by doing extraction or use
all the natural staining in your sample
to
answer any scientific question you might
have
let's talk then now about full spectrum
profile
what it is and how it works and how we
can use it for auto fluorescence
characterization
full spectrum profiling is a technology
introduced by sactech back in 2017
uses flow cytometry to characterize
single cells
cells that are in suspension cells that
are passing through
lasers and lasers are illuminating those
cells and light is going to be scattered
fluorescent light will be produced
and we will be collecting that light
three characteristics of this full
spectrum profiling are number one
it gives you high resolution data
because it has low noise electronics
and high sensitive detectors of light
we use apd's or avalanche photo diodes
for that determination
and the high resolution means that at
the end if you're interested in
cells that are positive for one marker
cells that are negative for one marker
the separation between negatives and
positive is much better
because of the detectors we use and the
low noise in the system
since we are part of the full spectrum
profiling is doing
a full characterization full across
multiple wavelengths in the visible
range
so we build spectral signatures we will
talk more about that
how we do it but the key message is that
since we do that full characterization
for
samples for fluorochromes what we have
at the end is the ability to put
together
more dyes in the same sample to
characterize the same cells
what we have reached so far is that
using a unit with
five lasers 64 detectors for
fluorescence
we can go up to 40 colors 40 different
proteins measure
in the same cell and simultaneously in
order to characterize things like immune
responses
finally a great feature of using full
spectrum profiling
is the characterization of
autofluorescence similarly to what we
could do with fluorochromes with
multicolored samples
we can characterize unstained cells and
understand the autofluorescence
and if needed then extract it in order
to
have better resolution how the system
works
the system has multiple lasers here
showing you a unit with five lasers
uv laser violet red blue and yellow
green
the lasers are specially separated they
reach the flow cell
the interrogation point where cells are
going to be
receiving that light from the lasers and
then emitting light
all the light that it's emitted will be
collected in multiple detectors
we have detectors like this ssc site
scatter detectors that collect the light
that
indicates granularity in the cells we
have two of them
one after cells are excited with the
violet laser and one more after blue
excitation
we have one detector forward scatter
detector that collects light that gives
us
an idea of how big the cells are frontal
light
and in addition to that we have 64
detectors
that collect fluorescent light after
fluorochromes are excited
after fluorescent proteins are being
excited as well what we have it's
modules of detectors for example the uv
module
it's going to have 16 detectors total
detectors that will collect light
from shorter wavelengths around 380
to longer wavelengths around 800
characterizing all the emission after
the cells
are excited by the uv laser so uv laser
excites molecules that light is
collected by a particular module with
multiple detectors in the module to
capture the full range of a mesh
similarly we will do with all the other
lasers and all the other modules one
dedicated module for the
yellow green for the red for the blue
and the violet laser
after capturing all that light in
multiple detectors what we
built for the fluorescent light is a
spectral signature
spectral signature is going to show you
on the y-axis the intensity of the
signal how many photons are captured by
those
detectors of light and then converted
into electrons
we will also be seeing on this plot on
the x-axis
the detectors of light this is the uv
module
detectors organize shorter wavelengths
to longer wavelengths covering the
full range of potential emissions for a
particular fluorocrate
from here we can see what detector is
capturing more light
more intensity definitely ub14 and as i
mentioned before we will do the same
for every excitation after violet laser
is exciting the cells we capture the
signal
blue yellow green and red and we build
the full
spectral signature putting all that
information together
in a single plot where we have all the
detectors of light in the system and the
intensity that each detector is
capturing
from this i can conclude for example
this particular floor the highest
emission is out of violet detector 14
and is excited by multiple lasers this
is the key difference
between using full spectrum profiling
and conventional cytometry
by conventional cytometry instead of
having multiple detectors what you have
is
one single detector that captures the
peak of emission for that fluorochrome
versus having spectral characterization
where you have
a more global understanding on how that
fluorochrome is excited
and it's emitting light across multiple
detectors in the different modules in
the system
what are the benefits of having that
full spectrum characterization
and having those specific detectors
it's the point that now we understand
better the samples
understand better the fluorochromes
what's their pattern of excitation
emission
doing that and not only focusing on one
single detector we now can use
dies that have a similar peak of
emission but the whole signature is
different
and we can use them in combination for
the same uh
panel and characterizing the same cells
and that happens for multiple
floor pairs since we can
um put more and more fluids then
we'll be able to build larger panels the
example is a fourier color panel that we
recently published
out of a single tube with high
resolution because of the
optical uh configuration and layout that
i described
in addition to that we can save sample
by the fact that from a single
tube we can gather more information
if you're interested you can scan and
read the full story on how we went from
three tubes for characterization using a
conventional cytometer to only one tube
again saving sample and doing a more
global characterization
and finally the benefit of full spectrum
profiling
is the fact that if you can understand
autofluorescence in unstained cells
then you will be able to extract it in
order to see
the real fluorescence in this case from
a fluorescent protein where it was
difficult
if the background is not extracted we
will focus now
on that how we do extraction but before
let me
remind you that if you are interested in
full spectrum profiling
this is our website scitecbio.com
in there you will find a lot of
resources things like tutorials
webinars publication including our 40
color uh publication from last year
and also you will be seeing there the
spectrum viewer when you can
build your panel and understand if it's
a good combination of fluorocrates
now let's focus on extraction or
autofluorescence characterization
using full spectrum profiling i'll show
you how we do it and from
now we'll be seeing mainly unstained
cells again because we want to
understand that intrinsic emission of
light
or the autofluorescence if i show you
lymphocytes and the
autofluorescence this is how they are
going to look across
all the modules in the instrument and
across
all the excitation and potential
emissions and different wavelengths
within each module
what we are seeing in lymphocytes is
that they have
a discrete intensity higher emission on
ub7
biolet 7 detector a little bit out of
the blue
no much emission out of yellow green and
red detectors considering this is the
zero in intensity
now that we can have characterized and
stained cells we can understand
how much intensity we are getting what's
the pattern
and how important is going to be for my
assay based on what i see on my
unstained sample
to extract or not that a lie that's
coming from and stain
let me show you a few other examples
other cell types how they look
let's look at red blood cells tiny
elements that
don't give you a lot of emission as
expected based on size and complexity
alveolar macrophages you know from the
scatter plot i can tell they are
more granular more complex and now that
i do
a more global characterization of those
cells
across all the 64 detectors what we are
seeing
is there the detectors are capturing a
lot of light
from unstained cells and the critical
point is that now within the plot
the space that i'll have to characterize
the real fluorescence from fluorescent
dyes from fluorochromes
is less and that's where critical is so
critical to do
extraction of this light to have it as
your zero
lymphocytes we already talked about then
discrete emission
and if we now look at uh these are
erythroid progenitors derived from
umbilical cord in humans
we are seeing also is that high emission
in intensity
high out of the by uv out of the violet
and critical out of the blue right here
we see a mission where p e is going to
be
showing you the peak of emissions so
critical that you understand that this
is going to be different from
lymphocytes that this is what you need
to accuse
exactly as the control for your
multicolored sample
and also identifying these areas where
these cells are highly autofluorescence
in these detectors
areas or detectors in which they don't
emit that much light
perfect to characterize the cells and
build
or build your panel based on the
observations just from an stain cells
important also just a few examples on
how different tissues
from the same mice are looking and
what we are comparing here is spleen
kidney
and liver and you see the differences
right
in the pattern of this emission across
the detectors
in the intensity lower intensity mean a
little bit higher on the y-axis
we see for example out of liver emission
on the red detectors
versus not much on the other two tissues
and this emphasize the need for that
perfect match
between what you bring as your unstained
control and what you have in your
multi-color sample
so if you mortical or sample its lever
but you do the correction with spleen
you won't be
correcting or extracting all the slide
that it's in the liver tissue
it's important that we provide your
software allows you to create multiple
controls
to have specific correction based on
your tissue based on your cell type
important consideration as i mentioned
before is that your staining protocol
can modify the amount of
autofluorescence you are getting from
the cells these are the same pvmcs just
treat it differently
fresh fixed with formaldehyde and
permeabilize with fox speech
what we are seeing is for just two more
similar pattern
but for this one changes especially here
in the yellow green
a lot of yellow green emission important
then
that it's not only have a match for your
cell type for your tissue
it's also how you treated the cells how
you treated the multi-color versus how
you treated your
unstained control to have that perfect
extraction
uh based on what you're seeing and
staying cells
and one cool example and these are algae
species with we have uh three microalgae
different
species synecocus nanochloropsis and
isocrysis
what we have seen is that without any
exogenous
dye any staining in this um micro algae
we are seeing emission emission of light
coming from photosynthetic
pigments from accessory pigments like
apc
like pe naturally occurring in this um
in this species and the important part
is
now without adding any staining you can
start characterizing
this samples and understanding how
things
change how dimension changes where the
cyanobacterium are treated when they are
exposed to different micro
environments it's important that it's
not only
uh the autofluorescent helps funeral
need to extract be able to
to extract it but also to understand
your system without any
additional stain and this is a situation
that you might have been seeing on your
samples already
and as you run your your cells from the
scatter plot forward scatter and side
scatter but we are seen as
multiple subsets when you look at the
full characterization of
autofluorescence in all our detectors
you are seeing that the pattern is not
that clear as we were seeing before
one single box out of each detector we
are seeing multiple
profiles with differences in intensity
and in the pattern
well in that case what you could do if
we
gate on those different subsets on the
scatter plot
we based on on defining low mid
and high populations and then looking at
their profile across the full
characterization
if we compare low and mid looks similar
in the pattern we can tell that meat is
a little bit brighter on intensity
and definitely the height scatter
population
it's showing us a completely different
characterization in the ups and downs
and intensity as well
but this is visually inspecting the
plots the best way to compare and
understand if they are different or not
it's to look at the numbers look at the
median intensities
for each detector and then plotting them
together
if we compare the intensity across one
single detector
let's say intensity for violet 7 was for
this sample
10 to the third 10 to the 4 and then ten
to the fifth clearly changes in
intensity which is what we call
changes in brightness we can also
compare
across the full signature compare
the spectrum the ups and downs
for this full emission profile and
understand if they are different or not
so if we want to compare taking into
account the brightness
we can plot the median intensity of
fluorescence
across all those detectors and see
clearly here how high that population
with hive scatter
has higher intensity of emission across
almost all the detectors when compared
to the mid population and the lower
population
we can also compare the spectrum the
full profile
in order to do that you want to
normalize having the same scale for
all the signatures from 0 to 1 in this
case
where 1 for each data set will represent
the peak of emission
biolog3 as we see here for the mid and
low
and a completely different peak for the
height scatter
around violet 7 as we were seeing here
as well
now that i compare on the same scale i
can understand if there are differences
in the x spectrum as i see mid and low
are very similar in the spectrum
and the opposite happens with the height
scatter see
different in multiple areas of that
profile that was created including
yellow green and red
so now that i know if they are different
in brightness different spectrum
i can use the software to do the
autofluorescence extraction
let's see how it's done and there's
nothing additional that you need to do
it's letting the software do all the
calculation and using the information
from your and stain
to correct and extract that amount of
light
what we use for that is spectral and
mixing it's an algorithm that allows you
to calculate
on the software the contribution of each
floor
to your multi-color sample and that also
includes the contribution of your out of
fluorescence coming
using the control from the unstained
cells this is how a multicolored sample
will look
it's going to have multiple floors in
there the out of fluorescence
so the software or the algorithm is
going to characterize how much light
we're getting from the full sample
understand what components are there and
for that we use single color controls
one control per floor so we would use
one for
bro for the biola die one for the blue
dye one for a red diet here
and also unstain cells to know how much
light
on trinsect like is being produced in
this system
once the software is gonna do it's gonna
start extracting first it's gonna
subtract the autofluorescence
and then gonna start deconvolving the
signal removing what's violet what's
red and what's blue and finally until
the equation equals to zero
after this you have two options first
option with
just a regular and mixing is to add back
that autofluorescence
or you could let the system extract it
in that case when extraction is done
what we are doing is defining out to
fluorescence as another floor
in your panel characterize it from the
unstained cells
and then being able to do the
computational removal of it
so let's see how in real data that
removal looks like
we have human pvmcs stain with a 18
color panel and here the
scatter profile have we want to focus on
on
low scatter cells lymphocytes
these are unstained deposits i've shown
you this profile before
and let's look at what happened after
the staining
without using extraction of
autofluorescence
after we get it on lymphocytes we care
about the cd3 positives and this is
gated on the cd3 positives
we are looking for cd4s or cd8
and the plot shows us double negative
events
and double positive or single positives
for each mark
what we are seeing here is that the
separation between my negative cd8
and my positive cd8 it's not that clear
it's difficult to see the the separation
or low resolution because all this
light all the signal in the negatives we
are seeing
it's coming actually this is brilliant
violet 570 for
all from all this light that unstained
cells are giving us in that particular
detector which is the primary detector
for 570.
so the light's still there that's the
background and that's what we are seeing
that's why it's high in intensity 10
to the fourth similarly for cd4 high on
intensity
and also similar when we get only on
cd8s
to understand memory subsets ccr7 cd45
array
we are seeing how close negatives and
positives are
in this case and in the same way for the
other marker
well if you do one click on the software
to do out of fluorescence extraction now
what we are seeing is that
all this light coming from the unstained
sample
will be extracted will be now your zero
and what we are seeing is that the
negative population that we were seeing
here
close to the positives is now down to
zero perfect symmetry around zero
and my ability to call what's positive
is much much better because of the
better resolution
in this plot compared to the top one and
also on this plot compared to
what we are seeing really close
populations versus better separated ones
this is an example but what i want to
describe
now it's what you need to do
based on how your sample looks how
complex the sample is
you could have different situation or
scenarios you could have a very
homogeneous
sample cell lines solder cells
but most of your cells are going to have
similar brightness similar spectrum
so extraction can be definitely useful
based on what you're seeing on the cells
we will describe
examples for each of them just may just
give you a general idea what are the
different scenarios
you could have very heterogeneous
samples as well where your
tube has more than one population let's
say lymphocytes and monocytes
and then you could have differences in
brightness based on how complex
and how big those cells are but it could
be the case that even though they are
different in brightness they have
similar
spectrum remember the ups and downs in
that signature profile
and the the most difficult scenario
where you have a very heterogeneous
sample let's say a co-culture of
lymphocytes and dendritic cells
lymphocytes and tumor cells
alveolar macrophages where the cells are
not going to be different
only based on brightness but also based
on the spectrum
so let's go one by one let's start with
homogeneous samples
easier to do the extraction these are
induced pluripotent
stem cells that were transformed to
express a
gfp a fluorescent protein from the
scatter plot what i'm seeing is that
it's a very homogeneous population
one single subset in that plot when we
look at those cells
in the spectral uh signature what we are
seeing is that yeah
we can clearly see the pattern the
intensity
but in general these rainbow boxes
indicators out of each detector are
really tight
telling me that is a homogeneous
population
and that we are dealing with one single
autofluorescent signature
critical now that when the cells were
transformed to express gfp
this is how they look what we are seeing
is the gfp
primary detector b1 but below
the background this autofluorescence
emission
in the cells even when they don't have
any fluorescent protein
that it might make really difficult to
distinguish what's the real
positivity so if we go and do
unmixing with and without
autofluorescence extraction let's see
what we get
for this non-transform kind of the
unstained control what we are seeing is
there is a lot of background
kind of occupying half of your plot
and this is now the area that we will
have to define what's gfp
positive in this gfp expressing ones
if we do a mixing without extraction
what we see is the high background of
the negatives
our positives really deem as we were
seeing before
and issues with identifying or
separating
positives from negatives if we now do a
mixing with autofluorescence extraction
all these lights from the negatives will
be extracted now it's going to be your
zero
and the positives will stay at the same
intensity but now my ability to separate
these positives gate on them it's
clearly much much better
and and better estimation of the
positivity when extraction is done
because this negative or this
non-transfected this background was
extracted considering the background as
a new floral chrome new
autofluorescence attack in your panel
one more example this time without
showing you uv
illumination because you still can do it
on other configuration if you don't even
if you don't have uv
modules or uv laser these are hela cells
again very homogeneous the spread of the
data the cvs for these rainbow boxes are
really tight
which indicates this homogeneous sample
you're dealing with
high background from the non-transform
in the critical detectors
for your m cherry expression and again
that might make difficult to understand
what's the positivity
non-transform high background on m
cherry expression
the ant mix for m cherry we are seeing
the positives but the high background
makes difficult to know where to get
versus the unmixing with
autofluorescence extraction
we can now see the negatives down to
zero the light got extracted
and the positives clearly separated
where we can define
percentage of positive cells for that m
cherry expression clearly compared to
without extracting the autofluorescence
so extremely critical
and easy if you have a homogeneous
population
if you have a heterogeneous now it's
going to depend on how different those
cells
are in brightness and spectrum
the case for pvmcs peripheral blood
mononuclear cells
is they tend to be showing you
differences in branded but similar
spectrum let's look at the scatter
profile lymphocytes and monocytes
if we look at all the events this is the
signature we get
this time the boxes are not that tight
this time what we are getting it's kind
of two
boxes on each single detector reflecting
the differences in intensity between the
low box the lymphocytes and the brighter
box the monocytes
what we get from here is that if we get
only on monocytes or lymphocytes to show
the profile now it's very tight
it's clearly distinct for them the
pattern
looks similar across all detectors and
the intensity is the neurolymphocytes
variety the monocytes
but visually it's difficult to conclude
the best way to do it
is exporting the medians for each
detector and comparing
we have a tool provided to you to do
that comparison
if we compare based on brightness based
on the median intensity of fluorescence
we see lymphocytes on
orange dimmer and on blue monocytes
brighter across multiple detectors
if now we use the same scale for both
taking brightness out of the equation
comparing only the spectrum we see that
they are
highly overlapping very similar ups and
downs
in those signatures that
are gonna be reflecting on the results
and let me show you for the same 18
color panel
those two subsets what happen if i do a
mixing uh with extraction
using one or the other one as your uh
new tag new florida chrome in your panel
if you use all the events or if you use
lymphocytes on monocytes
and here just showing you one plot uh
cd4 versus ccr7
a plot where we should be seeing double
negatives double positives
and single positives for each marker and
the same plot for each condition
if we compare across the three
conditions where
different subsets were used for your
autofluorescence extraction there are no
differences
because their spectrum was similar then
the unmixed data should be
similar the other case
would be where your populations are so
different
in the spectrum that you need to do
specific corrections or add
additional um fluorochromis not only the
one that comes with the software but
adding more and you can add as many as
needed based on how complex and
heterogeneous your sample is
in this case what i'm going to do is
show you an example what went wrong with
one experiment
and show you how the approach
understanding that the sample was
heterogeneous and then doing the
multiple extraction
helped to get better resolution into
data this is an eight color panel
these are bone marrow cells in mouse and
what we did initially was just
autofluorescence extraction
we have multiple subsets what we did was
eliminate unwanted events we removed
cell debris we'd remove
all these marginal bright events and
what we are getting
uh here is the uh the single cells we
remove any cell doublets and aggregates
we also remove death cells using a
viability diet
and we pay close attention to the
stability of the fluorescent signal
using time as a parameter after that
using a sample where the multiple single
color controls were merged
what we are seeing is expecting to see
is
the negatives in alignment with the
positives for each marker and multiple
permutations shown here
so we see that alignment we know there
were no issues
with the unmixing or the spillover
correction what we are also seeing is
this diagonal again not explained by
and mixing issues not explained by
having debris in the sample
not explained by having dead cells if we
compare the same plots
in this multi-color sample with what we
see in the and stain
we now understand where that diagonal or
those different diagonals are coming
from
in the and stain we see most of the
events low
on intensity for those floors but we see
false positives
in the diagonals have very similar shape
when we compare top and bottom
indicating there is an additional
population in this
unstained control that has a very
different profile of autofluorescence
that is giving us these false positives
on multiple dyes
and that needs to be extracted
independently
based on its own profile so having those
diagonals
where they are not explained by
any issues with your and mixing or by
having
any antibody aggregates cell aggregates
or cell
death cells it's clearly an indication
that autofluorescence
is playing a role and the good thing is
since you have an
unstained sample you can understand what
happened and create
a particular signature just for this
population and then characterize it and
extract
so how do i know i have a high degree of
heterogeneity in my sample
well let's start with the scatter plot
from here i know i have
one two three populations and i can look
at their signature profiles
i was able to separate up to four
populations if we look at the low
scatter
mid and part of that height scatter and
if we look at the signatures they look
similar go up on a uv up on
violets in a similar pattern but there
were some events in that height scatter
that are
very different since we have multiple
detectors we have multiple opportunities
to understand and characterize those
events
understand they are different and then
use those difference to do
specific extraction our suggestion if
this is your case is when you explore
the sample this is what you're seeing
is now you can define an additional
autofluorescence
signature using these events and include
it in your panel
how would you do that we always go to
the same
way to compare the signatures
independently if it's homogeneous
heterogeneous and
differences in spectrum of brightness
the way to recognize those differences
is by plotting them together so that's
what we did the
four signatures were plotted together to
understand their median intensity of
fluorescence
and we see clearly how the high scatter
population is so different intensity
brighter than others
when now i compare the normalized
signature
zero to one same scale i can see how the
three that are low on the scatter are
similar
overlapping intermission and something
that is completely different
that's giving me a different spectrum
and that now i can consider as a
new autofluorescent tag new fluorochrome
since i have the unstained cells to
define that new fluorochrome
you don't really need to go and do all
that exploration on your own looking at
the signatures
there is a way to do it on the software
on the software you can calculate a
metric called similarity index
site to define this metric to understand
how similar
two signatures are the similarity index
goes from zero
no similarity to one identical
and that number can be calculated on the
software so if we compare
low mid the height low
and the high high what we're seeing is
the numbers for the three
initial ones are really close to one
indicating
that they are similar low versus mid
close to one
mid versus high low also close to one
that similarity it's on something that
we had
already concluded from here these three
signatures look very similar but the
software can make that conclusion for
you
what we are also seeing is that the high
signature
it's different from the others and with
as you would do with plural chrome
similarity of 0.98
or less than that tells you that that
signature
is unique unique from the other
autofluorescence
unique also from your fluorochromes and
needs to be extracted
independently what you do next
that autofluorescence that is defined as
different can be included in the panel
as a new fluorochrome we can
then understand how similar it is to
all their fluorochromes in theirs we see
intermediate similarity with per cp
now it will be corrected properly
and in order to do that similar to any
fluorochrome similar to what you would
do in conventional
having single color controls to train
the software and
understanding what switzy what's pe what
are the different fluorescent
since now my autofluorescence will be a
new floor
i need to have a way to understand what
that tour looks like
for that you will need to define a new
control
defining positives the signature we just
identified defining negatives the events
with lowest
emission and then adding that to your
experiment if we talk about the control
the rules for those single color
controls or reference controls the same
rules will apply
and similar to the rules that you would
use in for conventional cytometry
your control needs to be as bright or
brighter
than your actual sample your uh the
spectrum
in that control needs to match what you
have in the multi-color sample so now
the match is going to be
same cells same preparation in your and
stain and in your multi-color
another important consideration is that
you have enough events to
acquire a lot of events in your unstain
to do this characterization properly
and the last rule is that the negative
and the positive
should have similar autofluorescence
it's not possible in this case we are
starting from the point that they are
actually different
so we will define that rule and use that
signature as your positives and for the
negatives use the lowest after
fluorescence
uh as possible once you do that you
define the new one in your in your
software
the software will do everything for you
all the calculation all the correction
all the extraction
and what we will get at the end if we go
back to that example when i'm mixing
without the fluorescence extraction what
extraction for the lymphocytes or the
low scattered population
was giving us that diagonal is that now
that i know
what diagonal it is coming from the
height scatter
i add that height scatter to my
experiment i extract it
you see how that's impacting the quality
of the data and definitely eliminating
those false positives from every single
permutation that is plotted
but if we now look at their data how
that was impacting their ability to see
their populations of interest
if we go from and mixing and multiple
plots
but key points are they needed to define
cd19 double positives
there is some diagonals here the
negatives are high
in intensity and it's difficult to
separate what's positive and what's
negative
for all the other plots independently of
the marker what we are seeing that it
seems like they are double positive
they are in that upper uh right quadrant
indicating double positivity but when we
started
using and characterizing out so for us
and extracting separately
by defining multiple tags what we see
now
and if we compare top with bottom is
that
negatives are down to zero these
diagonals are eliminated
my ability to define positivity for cd19
it's much much better clear separation
and now for the other markers i see now
what's expected cd 23 for example
a subset out of the b 220 population
and cd23 a subset out of the igm
positive population
these two subsets that were deeming
intensity that were really
close to the negatives were not
identified initially when the
autofluorescence was not extracted that
autofluorescent was still there the
background
was masking these positive signals and
now
doing extraction clearly reveals the
true fluorescence of this uh deemly
expressed markers
the benefits of autofluorescence across
multiple samples are really clear
giving you in general better resolution
for your data
and on this particular part the critical
point is that you can define if your
sample is very heterogeneous you can
define
multiple tags to characterize
the different subsets in there out of
your and stain sample
and do the correction to get better
resolution
to conclude full spectrum profiling
gives us the ability to characterize
and extract autofluorescence if needed
in order to improve the resolution in
your data
we have seen how the impact of the
autofluorescence is going to be
different
based on what cells you have how they
are treated
and what are the staining protocol
so make sure that if you want to
characterize well the autofluorescence
you bring unstained samples with enough
events to characterize it better that
that unstained sample
matches the sample type and this
preparation method you use
in your multi-color and then then you
define what's the optimal and mixing
strategy by looking at how much light
you're getting how a heterogeneous is
and how many subsets you are present in
your in your sample
just letting you know and you can use
this code to get extra information on
our newsletter
we're going to have more webinars focus
on autofluorescence discussing difficult
cases with not only one autoforce and
signature but multiple ones were needed
to do a good extraction
when we will be showing you how critical
is now that you understand the output
essence in your cells
then how you design panel around that
what floors are going to be better
extraction needed
and the separation for your different
floors and the resolution
and finally some examples on how we can
use autofluorescence as a label-free
method
to conclude without any hexogenous
agents well
that's the end of my presentation thank
you so much for uh your attention
and i'll be happy to answer any
questions let me say thank you to a
fantastic team at psychic biosciences
our customers that provide data and
sets and thank you so much be happy to
answer any questions you might have
thank you diana for your informative
presentation uh we're now going to start
the live q a portion of the webinar so
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please click on the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen
and we're going to answer as many
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question
is about a project on aging
and they're wondering based on your
experience will aging autofluorescence
be a problem in
fact well the
for aging there are uh two studies that
i know
one is on and i'm telling this because
it's
both studies had the same conclusion in
terms of what protein was involved when
evaluating out of fluorescence
no by flow cytometry microscopy male or
imagine
so one of them is is using c elegans and
when c elegans is aging it produces more
light proof
fusion which is one of those uh
components within the cells that can
emit light red light mainly
so that would be an indication that it
could work that finding i know it's a
different
system but also in humans uh when you do
imagine of the eye as well when there is
macular degeneration
um you can also see increased levels of
light proportion so
that that could be an indication that
you can do the characterization upon
aging
then also there is a mouse study in
in brain characterizing autofluorescence
in microglia
and what the one of the conclusions is
that
cells or or cells from mild systems that
are aging
they see higher autofluorescence this
time not doing any specific
characterization
what component is but definitely
there are suggestions in the literature
that
aging is going to be increasing out to
fluorescence and in particular through
at least the elegance and and humans
through that liposuction uh pigment
which is just a light
pigment
uh let's go to the next question um this
one's related to tumor and clinical
samples where you may not have lots of
sample to do an unseen control
they're asking diana in your experience
what is the minimum number of cells
needed to be collected for the
autofluorescence extraction to work
properly
yeah that's a difficult point it's gonna
depend on how
frequent your cells with a different
autopresence profile
are what's their their yeah their
frequency mainly
so since we are defining
autofluorescence as a new fluorescent
tag
treated as any chlorochrome or any
reference control in your experiment
then the guides will be the same it's
500 minimum
oh sorry yeah 500 cells or events
minimum to characterize it
but what i've seen so far is is that the
more
the better the more cells you acquire
and i know it can be difficult
in that scenario where two more so you
don't have a lot of cellularity but
the best has been so far where you have
a sample where
many many events have been recorded 100
000 for that and staying control
in order to capture those populations
with low frequency that are the ones
that have different autofluorescence
profile
i would do it at least the first time if
it's a kind of a longitudinal study
with all your samples so you understand
better your system
your particular tissue your particular
conditions and on infestation or your
your infiltrator or the actual stromal
cells
but yeah a critical point uh having very
few makes difficult to understand the
signature
having very few of them makes difficult
to do the extraction
uh in a representative population of
what you will have in that multi-color
sample with more and more events
hey thanks deanna uh let's go let's try
and answer as many as we can so the next
one
is um there uh the next question is
about a panel where they're using more
than 20 colors and unmixing doesn't
actually work
like we showed um then they're having to
do a lot of
post unmixing compensation is there a
possibility to improve the unmixing
results
oh yeah we can if you know the name of
the technical application specialist in
your area we can help you review
what what we have discussed here has
it's not related to the fluorescence
controls or the
reference controls and the unmixing
calculation
to correct for the spillover between
fluoresce it's mainly
unstained cells and how we treat that
information so if there are
issues with your and mixing calculation
for the fluorescent
dyes it might be reflecting and a
problem with your reference control
that control for your cc for your pe and
not an autofluorescence in general if we
see diagonals is either
a mixing error because of your controls
or autofluorescence so two separate
things
one we use it we use the unseen sample
for autofluorescence to characterize and
then do that extraction multiple
extractions
if needed the other one needs to be
addressed from the
reference controls the quality of the
controls the type of control you are
using cells versus speeds
and how that's useful for the and mixing
of protocols
so my suggestion is to contact your um
your application specialist let us know
by in the chat if you know the name of
that person and we can
so they can help you understand better
on your data set what's the situation
and how
that can be fixed
the next question um
can you create an autoforces tag from
data that's already been acquired
and kind of on a similar note there's a
separate question is autoflex
is auto license extraction done post
analysis or
can we see the results live sure we can
we can do it live because it's once you
record
uh your einstein sample your reference
controls you
are able to do the unmixing
so that slide you can acquire your
sample live after doing the calculation
after doing the extraction
uh it doesn't need to be done after
acquisition
and but both options are available
okay great and uh see maybe one or two
more questions depending on
so the next one is it possible to over
over
extract your autofluorescence from a
mixed population for example on
lymphocytes if you have a lot of cells
with higher autofluorescence than your
population of interest
yeah our recommendation uh it's to
try both options with and without
extraction
because there are some cases where the
out of fluorescence is not really high
slow that the correction senses based on
the median from the end stain
will give you a unexpected results or
more spread in the negatives
so yeah it can be detrimental that
extraction and it's a it's a good point
uh for most of the cells especially if
you have big cells
granular cells it's going to be useful
but
uh that we have seen cases in which that
extraction
lead to less resolution so ideally you
can create two experiments without
extraction with extraction and compare
look at the resolution look at your
populations and from the biological
point
see if the results make sense
okay um and let's go to the next one
how do you define the detectors needed
to create the autofluorescence tag
a good point basically from that
evaluation that we do
looking at the signature profile where
you see
and if you see a very heterogeneous
sample
what we you could do one is check all
the permutations
and see where populations are separated
just from the autofluorescence
that's one option the other one is is
use that signature to guide
uh your selection or your definition of
what uh detectors to select
and by that i mean if in the signature
you see that there are kind of
two different profiles and one of the
detectors allows you to see them clearly
the separation that could be an
an ideal one the other approach could be
gating
if the scatter plot is different gated
on the scatter populations
and then looking at their single profile
separated
and defining what are the detectors that
allow me to
define the differences in order to
identify that population that will help
you
to define negatives and positives or
least positives
but if if the the selection of the
detectors
can be done in multiple ways as i
described but it's mainly based on what
you are seeing on the signature in terms
of intensity
and differences across the same detector
for the different populations
okay i think we're out of time thank you
again dionna for your time
and your insights into autofluorescence
uh i'd also like to thank
lab roots for hosting this uh before we
go
uh thank you all for joining us today
and for your interesting questions
any questions that were not answered
today by the speaker will
be addressed via the contact information
you provided when you registered um
the web webcast can also be viewed on
demand so lab routes will be sending you
an email when it's available for replay
and we encourage you to share that email
with all of your colleagues who may have
missed today's live webinar
thank you again bye-bye